benjamin on va amener tout de suite les
enveloppes merci mon chéri merci ça va
bien merci pour tout ce que tu fais et
pour tout ce que tu feras bravo la
france te remerciera balsam à il ya des
enveloppes ici je vous jure que je n'ai
pas triché je vous jure que je vais te
faudra absolument pas à huy n'ont alors
pas vous savez quoi vous allez choisir
les enveloppes ombre d'accord d'accord
alors vous choisissez pour moi et je
choisis pour vous ok il ya des
enveloppes numérotées de 1 à 20 celui
qui fera le plus petit chiffre ou nombre
bien sûr perdra et devra faire un défi
pour cette première enveloppe
le premier défi je vous le dis les
simples c'est le gage du wasabi bibis
j'en suis baba va falloir prendre une
cuillère de wasabi et d'iroise habib sy
j'en suis papa il est là bas ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais aller le chercher
il est là le wasabi oui j'en suis là
c'est bon allez merci on y va benjamin
c'est de la pâtée pour chien ça non non
non ça c'est si la bouche à bouche assez
séduit c'est du vomi d'isabelle
morini-bosc celle là alors je pense à la
et vous pressez l'attention allez-y
alors c'est celui qui a le plus petit
bien sûr tête de suspense si vous avez
tort à nouvelle star dont vous allez on
ouvrir les ongles vous êtes h pas mal
aussi
je suis vraiment pas mal
suivront bien bien bien moi oui moi je
suis très bien en moi je moi je suis
près de 15 plus prétendre je suis plus
près de 2,0 g plus petit qui gagne dans
ses plus grands à merde je suis pas bien
les aurais combien de l'estac
vous n'êtes pas bien donc j'ai gagné ma
vie j'ai pas qu'il avait choisi pour moi
maintenant à voir si la cuillère de
wasabi et devant la caméra ou fait
wasabi oui j'en suis pas attention pas
grave vous savez que ça vous arrive
alors le wasabi monsieur baba ça va
ça commence à arriver benjamin ça
commence à arriver alors à caution ça va
mais jean ta race
benjamin qui vient de dire ta race ça
fait du bien de retrouver la villa audi
va attention le gage de la réussite à la
farine et chérie alors attention on à la
reine des neiges ou pas on à la reine
des neiges
c'est quoi c'est la farine la farine
logique alors bon ok avec un an à faire
dans la sphère le gage du banana qui
sont de le gage du banana qui donc vous
allez choisir le perdre on choisira le
gagnant choisira quelqu'un dans le
public avec qui vous fera banana qui se
troue dans l'estomac c'est normal c'est
rien ça s'arrête allez-y choisissez vous
choisissez la mienne ou là où la
boutonné à la route elle m'a l'air bien
il est bien ou pas moi je suis pas très
bien aux [ __ ] j'ai 14 ans adore
j'arrêterai dans les valeurs éthiques
oui je viens d'inventer fils au public
et je vais faire de balle à la cuisse
donc prendre la banane parler de vous
bon il ya quelqu'un qui est très motivé
et voilà alors attention
benjamin choisissez qui vous voulez mais
enfin un homme ça marche à ses atouts
tout ce que vous voulez un homme une
femme un animal dans mes yeux
maintenant voilà monsieur de noeuds
papillon la tabelle m'attend nathan
alors moi mon chéri va c'est parti royal
et un merci à
à
du soin par la tentation attend 1
la gnac la mise en pension on va perdre
le dernier est le dernier des terribles
c'est quoi le dernier je vous le dis
c'est le gage du verdet non non non non
c'est le gage du verdez boire un verre
de soda dans lequel il vient de se
gargariser
il faut le voir vraiment au sérieux un
petit peu pas beaucoup passionné viendra
se gargariser ici je sais qu'ils adorent
ça à l'hélium veux pas le perdre si elle
a enfin comment ils sont surtout ne sais
pas du tout ce qui a donné moi n'importe
quel slogan
merci et vous tu là je veux pas le
perdre cela je veux pas alors comment
malin j'ai perdu je suis pas très bien
alors je suis très très mal moi mais je
suis pas et je suis méga mall à ces deux
c2c 2 av
oui mais je suis mal non montrer non je
suis pas bien
j'ai pas bien non mais je suis pas si
mal à la la la
bazana il a bien fait de venir sur des
huîtres de lui faire du bien alors c'est
alors commencé là c'est ici lien c'est
là et là dedans merci vous êtes le
spécialiste inverse philibert
dégueulasse non mais ne regardez pas de
regarder pas ne regardez pas les crashs
en plus
j'ai beau me
non je ne sais pas je n'ai pas pas janus
ed
la roue avant
vraiment j'adore le défi c'est d'aller
chercher le glaviot du fond de la gorge
il a été chercher des trucs man touba et
ça
les gens qui dînent au fond la meilleure
décision qu'on a prise aujourd'hui c'est
d'annuler ce défi jeu des maisons je
vous rassure je n'aurais pas but